we never really knew what she felt about
some pretty key moments she worried
about the future of the firm and its
survival was fascinating to know what
she really felt about megsit about Harry
leaving to to learn just how much that
disappointed her how much it hurt her
that you know her grandson despair would
and could turn his back on his duty and
and his and his Birthright because that
was something she never dreamed of doing
she always vowed to the crown to the
monarchy to serving the people for her
lifetime which she she certainly did she
did and that vow that she made when she
was 21 to serve the people of the United
Kingdom in the Commonwealth for her
whole life whether it be long or short
and remember at the time she was
Princess Elizabeth but she then knew one
day she would be queen that that Duty
that had been instilled in her right
from the beginning I think it was an
alien concept to her that someone could
turn their backs on that which is of
course what Harry did I know and this
Royal Rift has just been this
fascinating topic for so many people and
you write in your book that you say that
William hasn't been able to forgive
Harry stepping back for numerous reasons
so now that William is taking on these
additional roles and responsibilities
now that Charles is king and head of the
monarchy how will the Brotherhood evolve
from here moving forward now that they
are giving these new positions will we
see any sort of repairs in this Rift
between the Brotherhood well I think
everyone wants to see a repair in the
Riff because it doesn't do anyone any
good to have this rift at the heart of
the House of Windsor you know I know
that as much as as the King has got big
issues and they are big issues the
Commonwealth keeping the kingdom United
I mean that's what keeps him up at night
but he also has this familial Rift that
is overshadowing the start of his Reign
because it is generating headlines it is
generating talking points and it is
certainly something that he's going to
need to sort out I mean I in the process
of writing this book I really wanted to
get to the bottom as to whether there
could be a Reconciliation and I spoke to
AIDS past and present including one very
senior aide who'd worked with the
brothers for a good 10 years who knows
them both and still speaks to them both
and actually he was surprisingly
confident that there can be a
reproachment but it is going to be some
time down the line and that is largely
down to the fact that William simply
cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left
[Music]